The world is full of different foods, every
culture, region and era has their own distinct
cuisine.
But what makes some food taste good and other
food taste bad and why do different people
like different foods?
Let's start from the beginning.
When you chew food it is broken down into
small pieces, these pieces are then broken
down into even smaller pieces by enzymes contained
in your saliva.
These small particles of food then move over
your papillae, which are small bumps coating
your entire tongue, each papillae contains
between 50 and 100 taste cells folded together
like the petals of a young flower about to
bloom.
Hence the name taste buds.
The average human has about 10,000 taste buds
on their tongue.
Taste buds contain chemical receptors which
have evolved over millions of years to react
to five basic tastes.
These are, bitter, sweet, sour, salty and
unami.
Unami is a word borrowed from Japanese that
describes savoury flavours, such as roast
meat and soya sauce.
So that's the basics out the way, but what
makes people prefer sweet tasting food like
ice cream over, say, raw cabbage?
It all has to do with evolution and the history
of the human race.
Let's go back about 3 million years, at this
point in time humans hadn't yet developed
the basic tools required to hunt animals,
so they fed on foraged berries, nuts, herbs
and insects.
We've all heard the term "survival of the
fittest" but back then being fit meant having
a lot of energy, so naturally humans learnt
to seek out the foods with the highest energy
content.
Out of all the food groups, fat and carbohydrates
give the most calories per gram.
This was even more important about a million
years later, when humans developed tools and
learnt how to hunt, because hunting animals
requires a large amount of energy.
Sweet foods are laden with carbohydrates,
and 3 million years ago, the sweetest foods
available were fruits and honey.
But since fatty and sweet foods proved to
be very good for survival, our taste receptors
evolved to provide a more pleasurable experience
when we eat such foods.
Because it's in our bodies best interest to
signal to our brains, when we eat them, which
foods are beneficial and which could do us
harm.
Similarly our taste receptors evolved to react
negatively to sour and bitter foods because
in the paleolithic era, certain berries and
other foods which had bitter and sour tastes
were poisonous to humans or contained unwanted
toxins.
So our bodies developed "bad taste" as a defence
mechanism against such foods.
It just so happens that the types of taste
our taste receptors evolved to react positively
to such as sweet and salty, because they used
to be essential to our survival.
And now these tastes are found in many foods
which are detrimental to our health in large
quantities.
In our modern age where we are sedentary for
most of the day, we no longer require such
a large amount of calories to go out hunting.
So all those extra carbohydrates we don't
burn off, which, thanks to evolution, our
taste buds just love, instead clog up our
arteries.
On the other hand, our taste receptors react
negatively to healthy foods like vegetables,
because they taste bitter, which evolution
has told us, it must mean they're poisonous.
Because of this taste aversion, many people
choose to avoid such foods, even though they
know they're good for us.
Until 50 years ago sweet and fatty foods were
relatively rare and costly so gorging on them
whenever we got the chance was essential to
survival, it's only in recent years where
fast food has become so readily available,
that what we have to eat to survive is no
longer a concern.
As a result the number of obese people in
the U.S. tripled between 1960 and 2007.
Because our food choices are now determined
by what we fancy eating instead of what we
can forage, hunt or afford.
Some evolutionary biologists predict that
in the future our taste buds will evolve to
prefer the taste of foods that are beneficial
to our health rather than those laden with
fat and sugar.
Which means in 100,000 years McDonald's most
popular burger might be the McCabbage.
Okay, that's an awful lot of rambling on about
what you should and shouldn't be eating.
I'm sorry, here's a glazed doughnut to make
up for it.
But we all have different taste preferences,
so why do some people think this doughnut
tastes amazing, whilst others would much rather
eat this.
The surface of everyone's tongue is vastly
different.
People who have a high density of taste buds
on their tongues are called supertasters,
these people experience stronger flavours
than normal and often find flavours overwhelming.
As a result, supertasters often order mild
food instead of spicy and drink their coffee
with milk and sugar instead of black, to tone
down the flavours for their highly sensitive
palate.
On the other hand, people with a low taste
bud density on their tongues are called subtasters,
subtasters find flavours weaker and will often
order very spicy food and heavily season their
meals.
But taste bud density isn't the whole story
as to why we all prefer different foods.
Everyone's brain can recognise the five basic
tastes, bitter, sweet, salty, sour and unami.
However the group of chemicals that can trigger
those taste signals varies from person to
person.
This arose from different evolutionary threats
in different parts of the world.
Most toxic plants taste bitter, so in parts
of the world with a higher density of toxic
plants human inhabitants would have adapted
to dislike the taste of bitter foods more,
compared to people who lived in a less toxic
plant infested habitat.
But there are lot's of environmental factors
that have attributed to such a variance in
taste receptors in different geographical
regions.
For example people from malaria infested regions
tend to carry a gene that makes them less
sensitive to bitter compounds.
And millions of years of environmental factors
such as these as well as crossing gene pools
has led to a great variance in how peoples
taste receptors perceive flavours.
Which is why some people find this too bitter,
whilst others love it.